As Americans grow weary of funding
endless Wars overseas Democrat
warmongers have raised the stakes in a
senate briefing yesterday Democrat
Senator Jack Reed told Joe Biden's
defense secretary Lloyd Austin quote in
one sense this comes down to a choice
between lending Ukraine the tools to do
the job or seeing Young Americans facing
combat to which our defense secretary
Lloyd Austin replied I agree Senator to
which I
respond how about we do
neither how about that I'm not a senator
not the defense secretary but makes
sense to me war is on a lot of people's
minds these days as the war in Ukraine
approaches its third year with no end in
sight and the new war in the Middle East
completes its third week also with no
end in sight war is a fact of human
Affairs there always seems to be some
War somewhere for some reason and
sometimes there are world wars for lots
of reasons but we don't need to fight in
every war not every war needs to be our
war I've been thinking about this more
seriously of late than I ever have
probably because I have two little boys
and I am now firmly of the opinion that
I will oppose any politician who in any
way thinks it is a good idea to send my
boys or any other American boys overseas
to go fight for ab extractions in
Ukraine or Israel or any other hot spot
that tickles the fancy of the
self-styled grand strategists in
Washington DC there is no vital American
interest at stake in either Ukraine or
Israel I like both countries I have
immense pity for the innocent people
harmed in the wars but these types of
Wars are not new both countries are
currently fighting the latest stages of
territorial Wars that have persisted
throughout many centuries more than a
millennium in the case of Ukraine and
multiple Millennia in the case of the
Holy Land I'm not opposed in principle
to funding allies but as Democrats and
the Washington uni party broadly lose
the blank check for the wars they are
presenting a false dichotomy they claim
that the choice is either funding the
fighting or sending your sons to fight
and maybe die
themselves reject the false
dichotomy America has plenty of vital
interests becoming and meshed in
intractable endless Wars is not among
them I'm Michael nolles this is the
Michael nolles
[Music]
show welcome back to the show there's a
new fella on the Block who demands being
called ma'am at a restaurant uh we will
get to that very important breaking Tik
Tok story first though speaking of
Israel's war funding the hits just keep
coming from the new speaker the
Republican Speaker of the House of
Representatives because we're we're
about to enter into a period on of
debate over the war in Ukraine and the
war in Israel and potentially a war over
Taiwan with China and and as we debate
the funding I I have no problem funding
allies as they fight Wars when it is in
America's national interest and there
will be a robust debate over whether or
not such funding is in America's
interest but when the warmongering unip
party tries to threaten you that's what
it is it's threatening you it's saying
Hey give us your money or we're going to
go send your boys to die overseas for
Wars of abstractions that don't touch on
vital American interests that needs to
be rejected outright and those
politicians who would dare do such a
thing need to be thrown out of
Washington Washington DC and out of
public life now the new Speaker of the
House of Representatives this Republican
Mike Johnson he is a much wiser man than
all of that and while he is pushing for
funding for funding Israel at least and
you'll notice not quite funding the war
in Ukraine notice how he does it any
sense of the number of Democrats who you
think might come I hope that it's most
or all of them I mean there's a few
people who have philosophical
differences on that and we'll have some
intense debates about their opposition
to that but look this is a matter of
good versus evil I I think what prime
minister Netanyahu said just a couple of
days ago is exactly right it's good
versus evil it's light versus Darkness
we're going to have payforce in it um
we're not just going to print money and
send it overseas because the other
concern we have that is overwriting this
is our own strength as a nation which is
tied to our fiscal stability and that's
a big problem that we have as well we
have to keep it in mind as we try to
help everyone else how is it going to be
paid for um we're going to be releasing
that here shortly but um we my intention
and my desire in the first uh draft of
this bill is to take some of the money
that has been set aside for the IR
building and bulking up the IRS right
now they have about $67 billion in that
fund and we'll we'll try to take the
14.5 necessary for this immediate and
urgent need we'll deal with the rest of
that issue later this is a clever Guy
this is a really really clever
guy first he says we're going to fund
the war in Israel we're going to fund
our Ally Israel we got to get this done
right away because Israel faces an
existential threat a new war of
independence so he's bringing this issue
to the floor which will split the
Democrats it's a wedge issue for the
Democrats the
elite you can't call them they're not
all that moderate but moderate by
Democrat standards people they're going
to support Israel the radical leftist
young Democrats are going to oppose
Israel because they support Palestine
and and probably support a lot of them
uh that's a good wedge issue to hit the
Democrats on get them on the record it's
going to be a loser either way either
they're going to vote with Israel and
lose their base or they're going to vote
against Israel and lose their donors and
the more clubbable members of the
Democrat Party either way though they
lose something so politically that's
very clever it's also clever because by
rushing the Israel funding you decouple
Israel funding from Ukraine the Ukraine
funding is deeply unpopular most
Americans don't want to fund that war
probably most Americans are fine funding
Israel so it's it's a nice way to split
those things off there and then this guy
manages to score a third win here which
is he says look we have to be fiscally
responsible of course we need to offset
this funding yeah I agree we're not just
going to have the money printer go bur
and give that money overseas for
intractable land Wars no no we need to
offset it how about we pull it from the
IRS and he even picked the perfect
government agency to take it from
because if he said I want to take it
from the EPA
or the Department of Education or any
other of these bloated federal agencies
that that don't do very much good and
and do a lot of harm some people are
going to say well I like the environment
don't defund the EPA somebody's going to
say well I like education don't defund
the
Education Agency don't do that
please but everyone hates the IRS
everyone hates the IRS everyone hates
Bank taxes everyone knows that the IRS
is bloated the fact that they've just
added many many new IR agents some of
whom are apparently going to have guns
to come and take more of our money
that's the perfect one to pull it from
and so it'll probably still get shot
down certainly by Joe Biden but even by
a lot of Democrats in the house but
it'll get those Democrats on the record
I think this new speaker is a pretty
clever guy and the libs hate him they
hate him so much the libs kind of like
John Boehner the libs kind of like Paul
Ryan the libs are a little less
favorable but still are not don't they
don't totally hate Kevin
McCarthy the libs have probably
forgotten about how much they hated new
INRI so they they okay with new kingri
broadly I think but this guy Mike
Johnson they hate him here's the big
Scoop from Liberal David Korn over at
Mother
Jones the scoop is that Mike Johnson is
such a crazy religious fanatic
right-winger that he urged a religious
test for politicians I'm just going to
read verbatim What what Mother Jones
writes though Johnson is now second in
the line of presidential succession
we're still finding out basic and
important facts about him and how he
sees the world this includes his
alarming record as a hardcore
conservative cultural
Warrior great motivated by a Christian
fundamentalist belief I'm not a
fundamentalist per se but broadly speak
yeah that's good Christian belief that's
very good who has fiercely opposed gay
rights here we go all right we're
talking now baby uh comparing
homosexuality to pedophilia uh called
for a total Nationwide ban on abortion
great proposed the end of no fa divorce
awesome urged to return to 18th century
values I I guess the only reason I don't
like that as much is I would prefer a
return to 13th century values but 18th
century values I guess would be an
improvement Mother Jones Goes On One
More significant thing I've discovered
is that Johnson appears to have to
believe in a religious litmus test for
politicians now hold on this part
actually could be unconstitutional the
the Constitution is very clear there
will be no religious test for public
office so has Mike Johnson here veered
into some unconstitutional advocacy well
what does he mean by a religious litness
test Mother Jones goes on Johnson and
his wife Kelly Johnson a self-described
Christian counselor a few years ago
created a seminar that promoted the
premise that the US has been a Christian
Nation well that that's just obviously
true all of the great stat Statesmen in
American history have said that exact
thing going back to the pilgrims and
Plymouth Rock and 1620 going to Governor
Winthrop a model of Christian charity
going to the founding fathers who
invoked God all the time going to John
Adams who who said that the morality of
America will be the Christian morality
to who said that the constitution is
built for a moral and religious people
by which he meant a Christian people
John Jay who said that we shouldn't even
elect non-christians but you know
obviously the Constitution prohibited a
religious test much could be said about
that and but all the going all the way
up to to Ronald Reagan who said that
America is a shiny city on a hill going
up to our Pledge of Allegiance going up
to all of American public life we're
obviously a Christian country so is that
what they mean no he goes on uh Mother
Jones says the Johnson's are DieHard
fundamentalists who believe every
religion other than their brand of
Christianity is
false yes that's what that's what having
a religion means if that's what having a
belief in anything means forget even put
religion aside for a second if you
believe in a certain conception of
physics then you believe that every
other conception of physics is false if
you believe in the uh heliocentric model
of the cosmos then you think that the
geocentric model and all the other ones
that contradict the heliocentric model
are
false that's just called the law of
non-contradiction if you believe
something then you disbelieve in things
that contradict the thing that you
believe in that's not unique to Mike
Johnson's brand of fundamentalist
Christianity that's not unique to
Christianity that's not unique to it's
that's called thinking and having a
belief in anything about anything but
then they get down to it okay they get
down
to what Mike Johnson has done that
violates the prohibition against a
religious test first though just as as
Mother Jones says that Mike Johnson
doesn't look very good when you want to
look good you got to check out Jus cell
right now go to genucell.com
our friends over at genus cell have
launched a new product called genus cell
3 which works fast on your under eye
bags and puffiness genus cell 3 uses
advanced technology to deliver complex
vitamins and minerals directly to your
face for instant hydration it's like
Gatorade for your skin this new genus
cell technology keeps your skin looking
young and healthy for years to come the
genus cell fall Classics package also
includes a jawline treatment for a more
firm neck and jawline it also includes
genus cell's anti- wrinkle moisturizer
and deep Firming Serum of course any
genus cell Luxury Box is not complete
without the great genus Cel XV anti-
wrinkle moisturizer and their world
famous deep Firming Serum get your skin
ready for the cold and dry weather if
you do not look and feel your absolute
best you'll get your money back no
questions asked go to jus.com
kwes or you can call 800 skin 211 for
extra discounts on this amazing fall
package get results in 12 hours or less
the immediate effects are included for
free jus.com
Wes or call 800 skin SK i n 211 okay
here it is this is what Mother Jones
says is so terrifying about the new
Republican speaker of the house this is
the proof that he wants a religious
litmus test for public
office right you better sit down any
candidate this is what Mike Mike Johnson
has said you better sit down any
candidate who says they're going to for
legislature and say I want to know what
your worldview is I want to know what to
know what you're thinking about the
Christian Heritage of this country I
want to know what you think about God's
design for society have you ever thought
about that if they hadn't thought about
it you need to move on and find somebody
who has we have too many people in
government who don't know any of this
stuff they haven't even thought about
it so that's That's Mike Johnson's
advice to voters Mike Johnson tells
voters hey you should vote for people
who think like me not people who
disagree with how I think so Mike Mike
Johnson just told voters what every
single politician has always told voters
regardless of party or
belief the proof that he's totally
unacceptable and unconstitutional and
evil and scary is that
he says the same things that every
politician has always said
H H that's that's that's not a very
strong case is it
[Music]
now gearing in here on what those
substantive beliefs beliefs are we look
at all of them they're they're just
they're generally pretty great is this
guy is this guy the greatest Speaker of
the House we've ever had I know he's
only been in office for about five
minutes now but this guy seems right on
the money as all the squish Republicans
all the so-called conservatives decide
that they're going to make their biggest
fight defending the Democrat status quo
of 5 years ago you've got this guy who's
just saying true things things that have
been true forever and that will always
be true and he's not afraid to say it
this guy seems terrific this guy I'm I'm
sure he'll disappoint me or I fear that
he'll disappoint me like all politicians
disappoint us but generally speaking I
think this guy's terrific I'm very I'm
very Pro Mike
Johnson very because Mike Johnson's very
Pro God and that's good I like that
speaking of God Matthew Perry rest in
peace uh is he's going around the
internet in all of these clips of him
and some of his final days and years and
there's one clip that's particularly
poignant where Matthew Perry is
discussing what he thinks about God I
was put on a thing called an eemo
machine which you having read the book
you would know what that is but it's a
it's no I did I took notes I underlined
it it's oh no I believe you um but they
call that a Hail Mary that's what they
do when uh they put you on neck machine
when it's a ha Mary and five people were
on ECMO that night and the other four
died and and I somehow made it well um
what God is a is a fan yeah I mean I
know you're feeling about that um but I
I well I know I'm a fan maybe I'm not
okay I I know that uh once you've
referred to it as a force and you know
it I believe I believe that I believe
that a higher power there is higher
power I believe of close relationship
with him that's helped me a lot and
somebody's on your side yeah this is
really nice some people are going to
recoil just a little bit from Matthew
Perry using this vague language of a
higher power but first of all he's
talking to Bill Maher who's one of the
most famous atheists in the country so I
think he's just trying to get through to
him a little bit it's not a debate that
they're having he's just trying to
convey this year and then even when he
says look you've talked about like a for
spill well yeah that's kind of what I
believe in and I think I have a close
relation reltionship with him so there
you see he tips his hand he's not
talking about some abstract Force he's
talking about a personal God and he says
I think I have a close relationship with
him and that has helped me a
lot and I I don't doubt
him I didn't read Matthew Perry's book
Drew read it and after he read it he
called me or I saw him he said he was
like you got to read Matthew Perry's
book I said what why he said it's really
poignant it's it's it's just it's so
Illuminating and he he described a scene
in Perry's life from the book was the
first time Perry prayed he apparently
said please God make me famous you can
do anything you want to me just make me
famous and three weeks later the guy
gets cast in friends one of the biggest
TV shows of all
time and go God did not forget about
it this reminds me of a famous verse of
scripture which is ask and it shall be
given to
you which is why you've got to be
careful of what you ask for
because when we make an idol out of
something and we desire that thing above
all things we get it and and then we're
the dog that caught the car and
sometimes that thing is not for our
flourishing it's not been in our best
interest and sometimes that thing can
destroy us that happens all the time
with Fame in Hollywood I'm not sure that
I can name I know a lot of very
successful actors because I lived in La
for a long time and been around Show
Business a little bit
and I don't know that I could name a
single happy one may maybe a handful of
exceptions
maybe I'm talking successful guys I'm
not talking about unsuccessful guys
you've got to be very very careful for
what you wish for there have been things
that I've desired in life that I haven't
gotten that I was really upset about
that I didn't get and then in retrospect
I think oh that would have ruined my
life had I gotten that my life is so
much better now because God had a better
plan than I did and so I Matthew Perry
said apparently in some of his final
days he said I know that when I die I'm
just going to be remembered as Chandler
being from friends but I hope I'm
remembered for more than that and just
how I've tried to help people and helped
addicts and things like that and
uh that might be true he he probably
won't he'll he be remembered as Chandler
Bing but he might be remembered for some
of these
poignant things I mean the fact that his
book was such a big hit and it was so
helpful and it it came out just shortly
before he died uh that's good and it's a
consolation that that the guy had a
relationship with God you know we hope
that everyone comes into the fullness of
truth but any little step in the right
direction is hopeful and it's why
especially troubled people can be a
great guides for the rest of us because
we we see The Logical consequences of
vice and sin they know it better than
anybody you know and and so they're
they're often the ones who are some of
the best evangelists so anyway worth
worth praying for Matthew Perry and a
really uh a poignant end to an
unexpected end to a career that's
basically known for some catchphrases
from a '90s sitcom now speaking of
things that uh really matter you know we
all want to store our gold up in heaven
um but we have to take care of the body
and things while we're here on this
Earth and so when you want gold here on
Earth you got to check out Birch gold
right now text nolles to 9898 898 yet
again we are facing the threat of a
government shutdown later this month and
yet again the administration will
ultimately deal with it the same way
they always do with more spending more
spending equals a lower value of the
dollar protect your savings by
diversifying your savings into gold with
the help of the Birch gold group here's
the best part when you open a gold Ira
with Birch gold for every $10,000 you
spend by December 22nd Burge gold will
send you a free gold bar just text
nolles kwes to 989 8.98 to claim
eligibility before Black Friday Birch
gold can even help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in gold
for no money out of pocket and you still
get the free gold bars with an A+ rating
with a Better Business Bureau and
thousands of satisfied customers you can
count on Birch gold to help you navigate
transitioning an existing Ira or 401K
into an IRA in Gold don't let your
savings become a victim of the further
devaluation of the dollar through more
spending text nolles kwes to 98 9898 to
receive a free info kit on gold and
claim your eligibility before Black
Friday to receive free gold bars on your
qualifying purchase that is nolles kws
to 98
9898 Faith Moore Drew clavin's very
talented daughter has written a new
rendition of the age-old Christmas
classic A Christmas Carol except this
time it's with a K it's a modern Twist
on the story of ebener Scrooge except
with a female protagonist in a world
where boss babes are championed at the
expense of Family Faith is making the
case that having what matters is far
better than having it all A Christmas
Carol now available for pre-order order
yours on Amazon or wherever you get your
books
today speaking of troubled people a top
advisor to Ukraine president vadir
zalinski is reportedly saying that
Ukraine officials are
stealing that Aid money that we're all
sending over to them like there is no
tomorrow speaking anonymously to Time
Magazine this person who reportedly as a
top presidential adviser to zalinski
said that the Ukraine government is
powerless to stop this kind of
corruption he says uh people are
stealing like there's no
tomorrow and officials do not feel any
fear of engaging in corruption because
the firing of the corrupt former
Minister of Defense took over six months
and it's it just it didn't really matter
that much so they don't have any fear at
all and this really matters not because
any corruption whatsoever is evidence
that we need to cut off all Aid and you
know let the dogs devour them but
because it suggests that Ukraine is not
capable of winning this war and
sustaining the
peace I've never understood the argument
that Ukraine was capable of beating
Russia in the long run I've never other
than the United States occupying Ukraine
and fighting the war for them I I've
never seen anything even resembling a
military analysis that would suggest
that Ukraine could win the war and
sustain the peace and part of the reason
for that is the long-standing problem of
corruption in the Ukraine government
these guys are willing to just steal
from the aid money rather than put it
into bullets and guns and weapons and
support for the citizens of Ukraine
they're going to keep stealing because
it's been a kleptocracy for a very long
time and this is a problem for us when
we consider our investment in
Ukraine especially in light of the
problems in Afghanistan the the most
shocking thing about the withdrawal from
Afghanistan for a lot of people was not
even that horrific attack on the base
that left Americans dead left a lot of
afghanis dead just as the US was pulling
out it wasn't even that we left so
billions of dollars worth of military
equipment there just abandoned it ended
up going to the Taliban now it's
probably being used in the war in the
Holy
Land the most shocking thing for a lot
of people was that the Afghan National
Army never put up a fight the minute
that the Afghan National Army which we
spent decades training
funding fighting alongside the minute
that they had to fight on their own they
folded within hours they just abandoned
their posts abandon their weapons
abandon their uniforms they were done
they didn't want to fight and if you had
ever read any of the reports coming out
of Afghanistan especially from the uh
spe special Inspector General for Afghan
reconstruction cigar which
coincidentally was the name of my
college cigar club the society for
intellectual growth and reinvigoration
also cigar spelled the same way it's why
I would get a lot of notifications for
the special Inspector General if you
ever read those reports you would see
the problems with the Afghan National
Army were so obvious one they lied about
the size of the army because they they
artificially inflated the numbers so
that they could get more military aid
you would hear reports from American
soldiers of these Afghan soldiers just
being high all the time on Poppy and
heroin and they wouldn't really do very
much and they would they would sometimes
engage in Friendly Fire and it was just
it was not I don't mean to bch the
Afghan National Army I'm sure there were
plenty of Brave Fighters there too but
the the Afghan National Army as a whole
was never going to work it was never
going to sustain the peace and so
Afghanistan was always going to fall the
minute America pulled out so the the
only options were occupy Afghanistan
indefinitely and just make it the 51st
state or make it an overseas territory
and American colony
or pull out and give it up to the
Taliban the second we leave but those
were the
choices and to somewhat of a lesser
degree though not much of a lesser
degree that seems to to be the case in
Ukraine whenever we stop funding this
war the war is
over and it might not be on terms that
we like might not be on terms that are
are happy for
Ukraine but the ukrainians cannot fight
on their own and with corruption like
this it's hard to see how they could
govern on their own even if they managed
to stop The Invasion From Russia
speaking of American Affairs
overseas governor Patrick baitman doing
business as Gavin Nome of California has
taken a trip to China because he's
obviously running for president he's
pretending that he's there on some
climate Initiative for California but
he's just there to meet with xiin ping
to position himself as a potential
president and uh as part of his trip he
decided to play a basketball game with
some nice little Chinese boys and he
decided when one of them was challenging
his Hoops a little bit too much that he
would tackle one of the boys so you see
here Governor baitman he's dribbling
trying to spin it on his finger that
didn't work Tres spinning okay he spins
a little bit again dribbling around does
a little twist does a little turn and
then he just tackles this Chinese boy he
got in his way and then he Nome recovers
pretty well they're they're laughing you
know he kind of Pats the kid on the back
hugs him a little so he's a good
politician gav Newsome but he just
destroyed that little Chinese that
little Chinese
child got just a couple inches in the
way of something that Gavin Newsome
wanted in this case winning a basketball
game and new just wrecked this kid took
him to the pavement can you even imagine
what he's going to do to Joe
Biden if Gavin Nome is willing to do
this to a Chinese child to win a
basketball game what is he going to do
to geriatric Joe Biden to win the
presidency a lot more than tackle him I
bet that
guy that guy is ruthless ruthless now
speaking of
psychopathy it it's it's that time of
the month for a i' been alone so long
but this time
I'm with you is there any Wonder looking
at something like that that people want
to withdraw from the mainstream liberal
culture it's true an entertainment it's
true in the news media people have found
alternatives all over the place it's
true in in political
candidates you saw you saw the dam start
to break especially with the nomination
of Donald Trump who came out a left
field who was totally
from the kinds of Republican candidates
we had seen in my whole lifetime you
seeing a little bit with the
Democrats Bobby Kennedy Jr polling
around 20% would be an example of that
and you're seeing it especially in
education and the Washington Post is
trying to figure this out since coid
especially more and more people have
been taking their kids out of the
schools mostly the public schools even
some of the private schools and
homeschooling them and homeschooling
especially when I was a kid
homeschooling was a thing that just
those weird conservative Christians did
that's not the sort of thing that normal
Posh clubbable people would do well well
now a lot of people are homeschooling
why is this the Washington Post is just
engaged in an examination of this I say
we're trying to figure it out number one
even as the pandemic eased homeschooling
persisted so they tried it out because
of Co but then they stuck with it they
didn't just send the kids back to school
when the schools opened homeschooling
comes off as
Fringe you well it used to be Fringe now
that is no longer the
case homeschooling is on the rise in all
sorts of places not just down south not
just in those hillbilly deplorable
irredeemable countries of the Trump boat
and whatever the Liberals think it's all
over the place religion is no longer the
the sole driver of it used to be just
Christian conservatives now people who
are not conservative people who are not
Christian are sending their kids to or
are keeping their kids home and
homeschooling them also homeschoolers
are more diverse than ever racially and
across all sorts of demographics and
then here's an interesting one parents
do less and less of the
teaching meaning they'll they'll form
little pods with different families and
sometimes they'll form even miniature
schools and then that will but but it
will be separate from a public school
and it'll be separate even from the the
private schools so what does this mean
it means this is the fastest growing
part of the US education system as even
the Washington Post
found and it means that it'll probably
persist but that last part I think is
key here because I'd compare it to
Airbnb
remember people used to stay at these
things called hotels and motels that's
where if you were out of town and
traveling somewhere and you needed a
place to stay You'd Stay what was called
a hotel or a motel then Airbnb came
around and a lot of people said wow I
don't need to stay at a hotel anymore I
don't need to pay all sorts fees I can
you know just say in some guy's house or
his apartment maybe he's got an extra
apartment and I'll just pay him and I
can use all of his facilities it's kind
of fun and it's a little cheaper and
it's wow this is cool but then Airbnb
started adding cleaning fees and started
adding this fee and that fee and putting
limits on how you could use it and what
time you checked in and all of a sudden
it didn't seem to be such a great value
anymore and so people started returning
to hotels and motels I could see the
same thing happening for homeschooling
if homeschooling is not driven by an
ideological or religious motive if it's
just because people got a little freaked
out during Co and they lost some respect
for the teacher unions and they saw some
weird stuff their kids were being taught
but they don't deeply object to it they
just thought it was kind of weird and if
they just they kind of grow these home
schools from their homes to their
communities to these miniature schools
and all of a sudden it's lots of
different families at a certain point
you're just going to you've just created
a small school and you're just going to
go back to the old kind of schooling
unless you've got a strong ideological
motive or religious motive for it if
you've got if you've got a a strong
driver why you're not going to send your
kids to a public school or even many of
the private schools were infected that I
think is where it's going to persist so
it will have been mainstreamed it will
be more diverse it will be in all parts
of the country it it
homeschooling is the way that people
were schooled for most of human
history the notion of widespread public
school that's the experiment that's the
new thing so homeschooling is going to
be mainstreamed but if people lose the
the strong motivations for why they
would
homeschool at a certain point they'll
Pro those those groups will probably
just return to the regular old public or
private schooling method my favorite
comment yesterday is from Chuck mauy
5951 who says I see YouTube is still
doing the coid 19 Flag thing they do
realize what the 19 stands for right
yeah we're perpetually 2019 we're never
going to get out of 2019 they're not
because if they called it coid 23 they
would have to admit that they haven't
really fixed anything and they they
would it would also seem a little odd
why does coid keep cropping up only
right before presidential election years
isn't that kind of strange wonder why
that is now speaking of schools Cornell
just issued an emergency alert for uh
Jewish students so uh they issued this
alert Cornell Hillel a Jewish Center
says they're aware of a threatening
statement that was directed toward the
building at 104 West which houses the
University's kosher and Multicultural
dining hall as well as more generally
toward Jewish students faculty and staff
the Cornell University Administration
has been made aware of the concerning
language and the Cornell Police
Department is monitoring the situation
and is on site with additional securi of
precaution at this time we advise that
students and staff avoid the building
out of an abundance of caution we will
continue to provide updates as
additional information becomes available
very bad stuff now part of this was made
online so it could be a
hoax I I'm not I don't think it's a hoax
of Jewish students saying this about
themselves I don't think so that has
happened that sort of thing has happened
often when there are anti-black
statements written on a wall or or uh
the white supremacist symbols or that
that has often been a hoax in recent
years especially in fact I document a
whole slew of them in my book speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
thank you same thing goes for anti-woman
you threatening what is called rape
culture statements those have often
proved to be hoaxes there haven't been a
ton in a recent American memory of
Jewish students doing these things about
themselves and we've seen a huge spike
in anti-jewish attacks and rhetoric so I
I I think it could
be I don't think it would be them doing
it to themselves but I could see it
being sort of a hoax because it was
online and people online make all sorts
of comments that that don't really have
any bearing in in reality but if I were
the Je you were students at Cornell I
would I would hunker down I would take
it very very
seriously the timing of this is a little
odd because I am going to Cornell on
Monday I was invited to speak at Cornell
a lot of the schools this semester some
of which are very prominent schools have
been dragging out the contracts because
the students want me to come but the
administrations don't want me to come uh
so we haven't announced a lot of my
speaking tour this semester this one
we're announcing last minute but it's
been the works for a while that I'll be
going to Cornell and I don't know what
it is I keep going to these schools when
the terrorists show up so I was at
Pittsburgh University of Pittsburgh last
semester and I showed up when antifa was
threatening to harm all sorts of people
and burn me an effigy on the street and
threw an explosive at the building right
as I went to walk on stage and and now
I'm showing up to Cornell days after
they're threatening to kill the Jews so
I guess that I guess that'll help form
my talk initially I was thinking about
speaking on I don't know some of the the
false premises of Enlightenment
liberalism could talk about the
political philosophy of Doo Cortez I
find that interesting but I guess now
I'll have to narrow it down
to actually you shouldn't kill all the
Jews that would be that's one potential
title maybe um you don't in fact have to
hand it to Hamas maybe that that's a
good title uh I don't know I got but but
I've got my work cut out for me and
anyway if you're around Ithaca next
Monday I will see you there speaking of
Close
Encounters goldi H you know actress
goldi H little little bit eccentric
Goldie H has claimed that not only has
she seen UFOs but she's actually
encountered them and they touched her
face
so Goldie H is in the camp of Matt Walsh
on the aliens
question uh the uh serious theologians
and philosophers and rational people
Threat all of History are they're in my
camp on the alien question Goldie hon is
in the sweet Daddy's Camp uh here's what
goldan said she said there was a time
when you know there was a lot of UFO
sightings I remember so clearly I went
outside my door and I sat on a little
Edge and I looked up at the dark sky and
I saw all these stars and all I could
think of was how far does this go how
little are we are we the only planet in
this whole wide universe that has life
on it I said I know you're out there I
know we're not alone and I would like to
meet you one day now hold on hold on the
way she's talking to these aliens is not
the way you would talk to aliens if
aliens were really just beings physical
beings from some other
planet because they probably couldn't
hear her right because she's
not because physical beings are
constrained by physics the way she's
talking to these aliens is the way you
would talk to angels or demons who are
pure Spirit who are not confined by
physical
laws right I don't if when I'm trying to
talk to Ben Davies well that's a bad
example because I have a microphone
sitting right here at my desk but if I
were to talk to Jeremy who's in hungry
right now and I said Jeremy I know you
can hear me he wouldn't be able to hear
me because he's not within the proximity
of my physical voice and he doesn't
listen to my show so if I were talking
to an angel though I could say I know
you hear me and uh I would have a
greater cause to think that the angel
could hear me because angels are pure
Spirit they're all
around This Woman's talking like she's
talking to Angels or demons she goes on
she say I know you're out there I want
to meet you she invites them in then she
says later on I get this high pitched
sound in my ear it was this high high
frequency she was taking a nap in her
car she looks out the window and there's
these two or three
triangular-shaped heads on little bodies
they were silver in color slash for
mouth tiny little nose no ears they were
pointing at me pointing at me in the car
as if they were discussing me like I was
a subject and they were droning I was
paralyzed and I thought oh my God I want
to get up I didn't know if it was real
or not real then she burst out of the
state of paralysis and said it was like
bursting out of a force field so there
are two things that this could be and
they're not necessarily mutually
exclusive what this could be at a
physical explanation is that it could be
sleep paralysis which maybe you've had
I've had sleep paralysis where you wake
up but you can't move you're still kind
of asleep but you're you're you think
you're awake and you have hallucinations
I've only experienced this I don't know
a couple two or three times maybe but
you you can sometimes hear something
I've never visually hallucinated but
I've heard things in the state of sleep
paralysis and then it's kind of scary
and then you kind of snap snap out of it
you can move again and uh it's fine
there is a spiritual answer here too
which is it could be that she was just
looking at demons they sound a lot like
demons and they kind of talk they her
experience of it sounds like how
everyone's described demons for all of
human history so could be that
too either way though not a lot of
strong evidence that it's aliens and
either way not not the sort of thing
that you want to
invite your move Mr Walsh okay today's W
Wednesday the rest of the show continues
now you do not want to miss it become a
member use code NES canw would check out
for 2 months free on all annual
[Music]
plans